Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Today, on Cutters Clinic, live, we have a great guest,
Megan Manzell, as her name. She's not a doctor. She has several degrees of nutrition,
nutritional counseling, spiritual counseling. She's been a friend of our clinic for about a decade,
I think. Now she works on the nutritional side of dealing with people with cancer and serious
disease, but even more so, the spiritual emotional side, and that is so critical. If you're not
dealing with that spiritual piece, I think you're missing a major piece if not the major piece of
life right there. So you're going to really love this episode with Megan. And again, I hope you
enjoy this interview. Please make sure you hit like, but if you're on YouTube, make sure you subscribe,
and hit that little alarm button so you don't miss any further episodes. Enjoy me right now with
Megan and Zell. Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters again and I'm here with a good friend of mine
that I've known for gosh, Megan. How many years do we go back? Seven? Yeah, at least seven.
2012, I think. Megan Manzell, she is a nutritionist, really specializes in helping people with cancer,
nutritionally and spiritually. And that's really what we want to talk about today.
And Megan, first before we get started, kind of give a plug for your website.
Sure. So I'm the one in CEO of Cancer, Peace University. And our goal at Cancer, Peace University
is to set people free from the fear of cancer. And our website is www.cancerpieceuniversity.com.
You've helped many of our patients just deal with that emotional side. So let's jump into it with
some questions about that. What's really the role of, in your body, your role of belief, thoughts,
emotions, but if somebody has this grave diagnosis, if it's cancer or some other disease.
Yes, there's so many layers to emotions, thought patterns, and beliefs when someone's diagnosed.
First of all, you have the diagnosis itself can trigger a lot of fear. It can actually trigger
the five stages of grieving with denial, anger, sadness and depression. And it's hard to accept
a diagnosis itself. But then you also have the thought patterns and emotional patterns that are
coming out of something called core beliefs. And the core beliefs really are the underlying process
of why someone has the same emotional patterns and thought patterns over and over again in their daily
life. So explain what a core belief would be. Sure. So some of you Pixar fans, the people that watched
Pixar movies might be familiar with Insights Out. And there's a character, yeah, the core memories,
but they start falling when she has a trauma of moving. So the Insights Out movie is pretty accurate
because those core memories are the places where core beliefs are stored. So your subconscious
mind will actually store your core beliefs that are developed from the womb to seven years of age.
And essentially those core beliefs are your worldview of how you view the world. And it's
conclusions that you come to based on your experiences. So it's subjective. So someone can have a very
small incident occur, and they can come to a major conclusion because of this memory, because of how
they process the situation. And this can cause a, I call it a maladaptive core belief that is stored in
your subconscious mind that will basically be how you interpret your reality and how you process everything
that happens in your life in present day. Your process circumstances differently based upon,
okay, if I was abused as a three-year-old, you know, so my trust for adults and trust in any
situation is not there. So give me some examples that you'd see. Yeah. And so that's a great example
because of course, any major trauma will be processed as a maladaptive core belief from childhood.
And it is a protective mechanism too because a child can't process emotionally a trauma,
and many times the body will store that memory and the trauma in a subconscious mind so that when
your adult, an adult, you can process the trauma. However, with cancer, these maladaptive core
beliefs can be a major trauma that is obvious, but it can be something very subtle. And I'll share an
example of a recent client. A recent client of mine was going through one of my modules on stress
is an opinion, core beliefs and cancer, which is part of the curriculum of Cancer Beasts University.
And as he was going through it, he remembered a memory when he was in third grade. And this memory was
so just a small memory of trying to connect with a girl in his third grade class that he had a
crush on. And he was trying to impress her and like be all smooth and funny. But she totally rejected
him and didn't think he was funny. And he felt so bad. He was so sad about it. He said he remembers
being sad about it for weeks. And he remembers just internalizing that. And that core belief of being
misunderstood or feeling rejected caused him to change how he interacted with people. And he became
very careful to not be rejected again. So he started to be a people pleaser. He started to change
how he would respond. And he tried to avoid conflict and relationships because he didn't
ever want to feel that way again. Well, you could probably put a lot of people into that almost
the exact same category right there. So what happens from a physical standpoint and as far as
disease of someone who is living their life as a people pleaser, afraid to offend anybody or afraid,
very afraid to get rejected again. That fear of rejection is a huge thing for a lot of people.
What could come out as a disease process with that? How does that relate to cancer? Exactly.
That's a great question. And so a new area of research is epigenetics. So epigenetics means
upon the gene. So our thought patterns, our emotions, nutrition, our beliefs can all trigger an
epigenetic response in the body, which simply means that it can cause oncogenes to express
or to silence or mutate health protective DNA like P53. And when that occurs, that can cause a
disease process by itself. But the emotions coming from the core belief, such as fear, fear actually can
cause over 30 different changes to hormones and neurotransmit and over 1,400 different changes
in the stress response system and changes on the biological level that actually cause a very toxic
internal environment that causes cells to change and really leads to a cascade of effects that can
actually damage your mitochondria. So one could probably say, I mean, I've said for years that emotions
are at least a piece of every disease. And so how do you go about changing them? So like with
this client that you had, he recognized this incident in third grade that created a cascade of
the way he has dealt with people since then. How does he go about making changes in that to help
his current disease process? Sure. So that's a great question. And a lot of addressing these
core beliefs requires deep thinking, introspection, and really connecting with an understanding your own
emotional patterns, thought patterns. Your brain actually has something called the default
mode network. Your default mode network is actually when you're engaged in deep thinking, it changes
the structure of your brain. But when you engage the default mode network and enough through meditation,
journaling, deep thinking about your life and about events or memories or emotional patterns,
this can actually cause a subconscious brain to give your conscious brain memories that you
may not be aware of. And I have an example from my own life that might help. When I was in college,
I just noticed a trend where I could cry and become vulnerable with my guy friends,
but with women, I just could never be vulnerable and I couldn't cry. And I just started with a question.
Sometimes we have to ask our subconscious mind, what is it that allowed cancer to develop in my body?
And why is my body having this disease process on the emotional spiritual side? And a lot of time
the subconscious mind wants to give us the answer. So for me with that question, why can I be vulnerable
with my guy friends, but not women? I was engaging in a process of introspection where I would journal,
I would journal all my thoughts, I'd write down all my thoughts and my emotions. I actually would sit
in Starbucks listening to Anya in one of the chairs that I'd be like crying in the corner of Starbucks.
And I would write down all of everything without judgment, all my thoughts and emotions. And eventually,
I would hit a critical point where I would pinpoint exactly how I felt and why. And that type of deep
thinking connects us to our subconscious brain. And through that process of deep thinking,
I gave access to a memory that I didn't, I wasn't aware of. And in that memory, I was in second
grade and I was crying and vulnerable in front of an adult of women in my life. And I am
shutting down. And because I didn't feel validated, I didn't feel in that moment the acceptance and
the love I needed. So I stopped, I shut down and I decided never to cry in front of women ever again.
And that is impacted me for 12 plus years.
Oh boy. And I'm sure so many people have very similar situations like that, that impact them.
But I think you touched on a very important thing with anybody with any disease is that
of the ability to do, you call the deep thinking, be introspective enough, ask the question,
it's easy when we get a serious diagnosis that we want to be a victim because that's what the
world tells us to be. Oh, you have cancer. Oh my gosh, I have cancer. I'm the victim of this disease.
Instead of saying, okay, this is what it is. Is there something in my life that has maybe not
been the sole cause, but that's participated in me expressing this disease right now.
And we're afraid to ask those deep questions. I think we miss a lot. And I think you'd agree with
that because we're not dealing with that emotional piece. So do you help people kind of bring that out?
And I think your cancer piece university really helps uncover it like it did for that gentleman going
through that. Is that right? Yes. That's one of our goals because
Japanese research has shown and discovered that spontaneous remission from cancer occurs within 24
hours of a profound internal transformation. And our goal with our clients at Canterbury's
University is profound internal transformation because talk therapy, you can talk about a trauma
all day every day and nothing changes because you're just reliving it over and over again and you're
not engaging in a process that will allow for profound internal transformation, which is necessary
for spontaneous remission. And you can also do positive thinking. You can think of positive things all
day every day and never impact your core beliefs. Yeah. All right, we need to talk more about this, don't we?
Because impacting the core beliefs, dealing, you know, that's what people want is that profound
transformation. And that's what you could go to authority and psychologist and talk about your
problems and your childhood for, you know, endless hours. But there are some key roots to that
profound inner transformation, your core belief change. And I want to get at the roots of that. So
could I have you back again, let's go over that and kind of lay out a dialogue and maybe put up
some charts so people can follow us. Thanks so much, Meg, our time is up for this session, but
let's schedule another one sooner. Let's get at some details of how to make those changes. I appreciate
you. Let's talk to you about some more time for us. Yes, the website is www.cancerpieceuniversity.com
and my email is www.cancerpieceuniversity.com. Thanks again, Meg.